before he entered politics senator-elect
barack obama wrote a memoir on growing
up in a racially mixed family
dreams from my father has been reissued
with a new introduction this talk lasts
an hour
[Applause]
[Music]
thank
you
well
good evening everyone
my name is lou pizzitola thank you for
joining us
on the morning of november 3rd millions
of americans woke up to find that the
man they voted for was elected president
millions of other americans
almost
almost in equal numbers
woke up to a great disappointment
for those americans there was at least
one saving grace
[Applause]
the man who had been the dynamic voice
of the democratic convention its keynote
speaker
the man who spoke of big dreams in his
own life
and big dreams for his country had
actually been elected senator from
illinois
and that man is our guest tonight
barack obama
in his convention speech our guest spoke
of his own father
a foreign student born and raised in a
village in kenya
he spoke of his grandfather a domestic
servant
and he spoke of the journey he has taken
in his own life
that story which brings him here tonight
is told more fully in his memoir called
dreams from my father
now there is much talk about what our
guest will be doing in the year 2008
2012 and beyond
and it would certainly give me a great
deal of pleasure to say that i was
introducing the next president of the
united states
and
it would give you a lot of pleasure as
well i'm sure
but what millions who woke up in
disappointment on november 3rd
might be looking to is what our guest
will be doing in the immediate future
based on the journey and the stands he
has taken
many americans should rejoice
over the voice they will have in their
government
a voice that speaks for expanding
opportunities and civil liberties a
voice that speaks to the promise
that we will eventually as he puts it
come out of the long political darkness
please
join me in welcoming the man behind that
voice
barack obama
thank you thank you
thank you all that's my best to say
thank you very much
thank you so much thank you
thank you
thank you thank you
that's i appreciate it thank you very
much
thank you so much
[Applause]
well
you know i know i made this speech about
there are no red states and blue states
but i suspect this state's kind of blue
just uh looking at that uh looking at
the crowd out here tonight
uh wha what a magnificent turnout i'm
i'm so
grateful to all of you for taking the
time out
of your busy schedules to to travel here
especially in new york traffic which i
just braved
um
you know i was mentioning that
when the book
that we're going to be discussing
tonight first came out which was in
1995-96
i had a much smaller
uh reception
but it
but this bookstore which had just opened
in fact was one of the stops that we
made and
it's wonderful to be back
uh close to 10 years later
and to see
how things have grown
so i i'm very grateful to to all of you
for being here
what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna just
spend a few minutes talking a little bit
about
uh
my perspective as it's expressed not
only in the book but also in the
campaign and and how those two things
connect and then we're gonna open it up
for some questions before we start to do
a book signing
um
you know i just had an appearance on on
charlie rose and you know he was asking
me how does
how does the book
connect with your politics
and it's very clear to me that there's a
direct line between the subject matter
that's contained in dreams from my
father and the type of politics that i
aspire to
because
essentially what this story is about
is
a boy
born to a father from kenya and a mother
from kansas
in hawaii
with an unusual name
who traveled to indonesia
came back
found himself in chicago
working in some of the lowest
income neighborhoods in the country
and then traveled back to africa
and somehow was able to weave together
a workable meaning for
his life
as an african-american
as an american and as somebody who's
part of the broader human family
and
that was not an easy task
it wasn't
an easy task not because i did not have
some enormous love from my family i did
it wasn't because i didn't have people
helping me every step of the way
i had that help
but it was because
i found myself
born astride
a nation and a world that is so often
divided
divided along lines of race divided
along lines of class
divided along lines of religion
and so we have this
enormous
tragic history that all of us confront
from whatever our backgrounds are
whether we're white black hispanic asian
whether we're muslim jew
or christian
the notion that
in fact
in the words of
a great writer
who happened to win a nobel prize
william faulkner he said the past is
never dead and buried it
isn't even past
and i think that all of us are
confronting constantly our history
we're confronting the history and stain
of slavery in this country we're
confronting
the history and
problems that arose as accounts of
colonialism we're confronting
those
those scars of violence
and oppression
and struggle and difficulty and hope
not only on the larger canvas of history
but also within
our own families
and
for me
it was not entirely obvious how in fact
i was going to be able to integrate and
pull together
all those different strands
in my life
so part of my challenge growing up was
to figure out
how do i function
as someone who is black but also has
white blood in me
how do i function as somebody who is
american and takes pride and understands
the enormous blessings
that come with being an american but is
also able to
recognize that i'm part of something
larger than just
a nation state
how do i
embrace
my faith now as a christian
also recognizing that i have people
within my own family who have a
different faith and and how do i
describe
the fact that we all have different
paths ultimately to
a same source
the same place
that we come from and to which
ultimately we will all end up
how do we do that what kind of language
do we come up with
how do we expand a sense of empathy
and allow each and every one of us to be
able to stand in somebody else's shoes
and see the world through their eyes and
as a consequence see ourselves and other
people
because it strikes me that
that's the only way that we're going to
survive
as a planet
and so that was in very abstract terms
what
the theme of this book is about now
in much more concrete and prosaic terms
what this book is about is
a boy who's growing up and doesn't have
a father around
and
what i i start with is the story of my
father passing away
killed in a car accident a father that i
did not know well somebody who had been
part of that first generation of
africans to study in the united states
and then had
married
an american woman
had had a child but then had gone back
to his own country
thinking that somehow he would be able
to bring back technology
and transformation
through the knowledge that he had uh
gained to help develop
a country that was
uh newly free
and i
didn't really know his story very well
all i knew about my father
for the most part during my upbringing
was the stories that my mother told me
so i had a whole mythology about who he
was fortunately the mythology that my
mother fed me was
was of a very positive image
so i write about the fact that in the
book
i oh i grew up
uh with an image of a strong black man
who just didn't happen to be in the
house
but was
one of the smartest and most charismatic
and brightest
and honest people that you would ever
care to meet
and so that was a mythology that i
carried with me despite his absence and
despite living
in a very different world than his
and it was only later that i started
realizing that in fact this was a
mythology that his life was much more
complex and
as a consequence of that realization
i've rebelled in all sorts of ways and
went through
a lot of difficulties that are not
unique to me in fact particularly among
african-american males
without fathers in the house
buffeted by a series of negative
stereotypes that they see or con at
least confining stereotypes of what it
means to be a black man in america
that
as a consequence of those things i went
in a whole
negative direction that lasted
throughout most of my teenage years
and what the book discusses then is how
did i pull myself out of it and it ended
up
being a matter of me recognizing that
the struggles that i was going through
internally to reconcile
a divided heritage to reconcile the
different strands of my past
could only be done if i linked my story
up with a larger story
the story of
struggle taking place here in the united
states with african americans the
struggle
that's taking place overseas
with
the millions of people who are
impoverished and don't have opportunity
and that's part of what led me directly
into the community organizing work that
i did the civil rights work that i did
and ultimately into the politics that
i'm still engaged in
and so
in some ways the themes of this book are
very much
the project of my life right now uh
which is to figure out how in fact can
we
uh live together as one people
effectively and what does that mean and
what does that require and what are
the nature of our commitments to each
other and what's the scope of our regard
and concern
and that's not an easy question
for us to answer we just went through an
election in which
i think
both sides simplified
the nature of the problem
and didn't necessarily offer very good
solutions you know our politics so often
functions as
one side
painting a caricature of the other side
the republicans haven't be better at
characterizing
democrats than the other way around
but part of what i
meant when in my speech i said there are
no red states and there are no no blue
states
was the fact that the complexity of our
lives
is not fully captured in our political
debate
that there are people
in the red states who are devout
christians
and
traditionalists who also think that part
of the american tradition is tolerance
there are
people in
urban areas
who
are
wine sipping and volvo driving
but also think that
that we live in a dangerous world and we
have to confront
the threats that we face
in
the strongest of terms
and
when we
simplify
our politics and we
caricature
each other
then
i think that we're actually going in a
direction that is entirely contrary to
the best spirit of this country
and i actually am a believer in american
exceptionalism i know that's not always
popular
but i i believe in american
exceptionalism that there is something
special about this nation
precisely because
this is a nation that is heterogeneous
and it is forced to constantly confront
uh the fact that we're different uh and
yet somehow
uh
there are a set of core values
and and and common beliefs
that can bind us together uh as a single
people and if we can't pull off that
experiment here in the united states
then we can't be optimistic about what
happens in
northern ireland or sri lanka or the
middle east
or rwanda
because
because we have so much to build on
and the basic outlines of the government
that we possess
and our civic religion as a people
uh is such that um potentially at least
we could
create a society that is the model for
the world uh it isn't right now
and that's one of the tragedies i think
of our foreign policy and our domestic
policy as it's played out over the last
several years
so
so the book ends
with me traveling back to africa
and retracing them the steps that my
father took and my grandfather took
my grandfather as those of you read the
book or will read the book discover
um was actually the first
african in his village and in his circle
ever to meet a white person
and
almost immediately he had to confront
what it meant to be
drawn from
a
15th century or 13th century
world into a 20th century world in the
span of a single lifetime
and the enormous contradictions
that he had to grapple with
he ended up passing on to my father
and those contradictions my father then
has passed on to me
uh w evie
uh du bois said that the problem with
the 20th century is the problem with the
color line
i think that oversimplifies as it's not
just the color line it's class lines and
gender lines and
sexual orientation lines and religious
lines
but
i call this book a story of race and
inheritance because the inheritance
the most important inheritance that i
received is
the fact that i've got to grapple with
these same issues that my grandfather
and my
father had to grapple with that my
mother and her parents had to grapple
with
and
that you have to grapple with
not only in your individual lives but
also as american citizens and as
citizens of the world
so
hopefully what this book accomplishes is
not to provide answers to all these
enormous questions
but it at least allows each and every
one of us to recognize a piece of
ourselves
in maybe my story
and as a consequence maybe you'll be
able to recognize
a piece of yourself and the person
sitting next to you
um and and i'll close by just
saying that i haven't had much of a
break since the election
uh somebody very charitably told me
i hadn't seen them in about six months
they said you've really aged since uh
i last saw you i said well thank you
very much
uh
but
uh
i am
gonna take a vacation
and and i'm going to go back to hawaii
for two weeks where my grandmother who's
now 82 and was born in augusta kansas
a little white lady
still lives
and she's got a bad back but she's as
sharp as ever
and i'm gonna
my sister also lives there and she is
half indonesian
and she married a chinese canadian
[Music]
and so with my um
with my wife who
is a descendant of slaves
from south carolina
who
grew up on the south side of chicago and
my two gorgeous daughters
um
malia and natasha we're going to be
visiting their new cousin
soheila
that's her last name
a little
chinese girl
who carries in her
you know my dna
and
and
the prospect of watching those little
girls
run on the beach or
crawl on the beach depending on the
progress that sohil is making
um
uh you know i think is is part of what
all of us
are working towards uh is making sure
that their lives ultimately are
uh rich and and uh
uh
blessed uh in the way that uh they
deserve so hopefully that'll be a
project that all of us will be working
on for many years to come
thank you
thank you
so
so uh
i think what we've arranged is to take
uh
a few questions and then i'm going to
get busy i got my pen all ready
um so
those of you who have questions i think
you have to line up and there may be
unfortunately a cutoff point because if
i'm going to be able to get through this
crowd and
we're going to get out of here by
midnight um
we we may not be able to take every
question so i apologize in advance for
those of you who don't get your
questions uh responded to
yes please
um i am the spiritual leader of a
multi-faith community that has felt very
besieged by the issues of religion and
faith in the way they've been used as a
wedge in this country i would really
appreciate your reflections on how those
of us who consider ourselves faithful
people whatever our faith can be more
proactive in combating this very
negative way of talking about religion
well i i think that that's a terrific
question you know there's been a lot of
talk after the election about how we
lost this election on moral values
um
first of all i think
it's an oversimplified analysis the fact
of the matter is that we were running
against a personally popular
wartime president
and one of the best political operations
that's ever been created
we had
some
mistakes that we made and we didn't have
any margin for error
during the course of the campaign
and when you've actually looking at
when you actually look not at the exit
polls
which were badly worded but you look at
where
george bush gained votes
and why people said they voted for him
he increased his margin here in
manhattan
as much as he did
in these so-called rural areas where
supposedly
moral values held sway and part of it
had to do with people remembering 9 11
and
ultimately not being persuaded that the
democratic party was going to be as
effective
with respect to terrorism i obviously
disagree with that and i could launch
into a whole reason why we didn't make
our cases effectively as we should
now having said that what is true
is that the democratic party has not
been
particularly effective and the
progressive community generally has not
been particularly effective
in
describing its values
and
a narrative
that relates to people's faith their
family and their community
part of that
is
what i think started off as a good
impulse and that was
our embrace of tolerance
and i think that there
is a running strain in progressive
politics and democratic politics
that
at some point i don't know when it was
exactly
equated religion
with intolerance
and so the fear was well if we talk too
much about religion then we must be
demeaning or putting down somebody else
so let's stop talking about it
and we then equated secularism with
tolerance now that's a dangerous
uh equation uh to operate under and i
think it's it's wrong uh you know
there's a reason why dr king
was such a good preacher
he was preaching
he wasn't just making a speech
and so those who
you know
were inspired by the civil rights
movement have to understand that that
was grounded in faith that's why people
were willing to subject themselves to
fire hoses and dogs
and
so i think it's possible
for us to reclaim this territory that i
think we've ceded to
a very narrow
and intolerant brand
uh of
of faith
uh but it requires us being active in
that arena and talking about our values
and and talking about
uh
the meaning of our faith uh in a way
that's inclusive as opposed to
exclusive now when we do that it also
has to be authentic
so uh
if we go around
toting our bibles and trying to
or our
whatever our religious text is
uh and try to
be more righteous than somebody else
uh then
we're playing a game and and people
will sniff that out
so it has to be organic and has to be
internal it has to come from within uh
and and i think that that's something
that um
i'm interested in in engaging in and
i'll probably hopefully be working with
uh people who are interested in these
issues
there is a problem though i mean there's
a genuine one that they can't be
brushed aside and that is that the
nature of religious faith
by definition
is absolute
but if you believe
in allah then you believe in allah all
the way
uh if you believe in that jesus christ
is your savior then
you can't say sort of
you believe that jesus christ is your
savior
and
the nature of
political pluralism
requires a certain measure of doubt
it's contrary to absolutism
it
it assumes that there are questions that
have to be answered and that i i don't
always have the right answer and
certainly that i can't trump
deliberative discourse simply by saying
you know god told me so
that's not an option
uh and and and so
there is that real tension and and now
all i can do is sort of say personally
how i resolve this tension is is by
claiming that in fact
my religious faith
is
premised on some measure of death that's
why it's faith and
not science
and so what that means then is is that
you know i can admit that
when i read scripture
that i'm in this constant interpretation
i'm trying to figure out in my own
sinful imperfect way
what exactly
is god trying to say and and if that's
the spirit that i bring
to the public square then you can
reconcile those two things but but
that's a it's a difficult
project
[Applause]
[Music]
i have a comment followed by a question
my comment is i hope one day you do run
for president united states i think i
should care for everyone here
well i know that wasn't a question but
let me just remind people i ranked 99th
in seniority
in the new united states senate i will
uh i'm gonna be as i told somebody the
other day i will be sharpening pencils
uh when uh and and sweeping up uh when i
get to washington so
uh i i hope people don't uh
don't expect too much
my uh question is
just looking at like a book of current
events or even before the election you
saw you know a lot of uh
books that's you know was for
president bush or for john kerry against
president bush against john kerry books
that came out as bush is a liar carries
a liar you know back and forth back and
forth where there's no middle ground
right
in the senate that's going to be more
polarized which you're going to join
soon how are you going to bridge that
divide not just culturally with abortion
guns and god and whatnot but just people
looking at so dif two different worlds
or two different americas
well
i think you're absolutely right that our
political language the language we use
politically is
it's it's more than just polarized i
mean it's it's uh
it's poisonous
uh i you know i can't watch most of
these cable news shows you know where
these guys are yelling at each other
ah what are you talking about you're
yeah
um
and i and i i confronted that in my own
campaign in the general election i was
running against a gentleman who
proclaimed that jesus christ would not
vote for me which
you know
my response was
i wanted to know who his pollster was
because if he had a direct line on jesus
christ i had far more important
questions to ask him
i
you know was i
[Music]
but
you know there is this slash and burn
take no prisoners
anything goes politics that
i just think is
so corrosive to our democracy
and by the way
i think is most damaging for
progressives
not only because we're not as good at it
but
also because what it does is it just
turns people off of politics generally
and then leaves that space to be
occupied by the special interests who
determine that uh
you know how the goodies are going to be
passed out
so
so we've got to fight that now how do we
fight that
the best
that i can do i think right now is to
try to model the kind of politics
that
was successful at least in my
campaign
in illinois and that is to try to
disagree
without being disagreeable
to try to find common ground
where possible
to
stand your ground on matters of
principle
but
not engage in cheap political shots or
impugn the motives
of people who
come at
issues
in a different direction
and
i don't know whether
how i function
uh
how that will play
when i get to washington we'll find out
but one thing that i'm absolutely clear
about i think if you know what your
convictions are
then
you're in a position to compromise when
you're not clear about what your
convictions are
then it just becomes sport
and
it's when politics is treated as sport
as opposed to
actually trying to get something
accomplished to help kids get educated
or to provide health care to people who
don't have it or
to help senior citizens retire with
dignity and respect
that's when i think
um
you fall into the kinds of politics that
we've been seeing um
one last point i will make about this i
i am disturbed about the fact that
our vicious brand of politics has become
so
commercially lucrative
i mean there's an entire industry as you
mentioned
you know these books
are all on the bestseller list because
they speak to
a
significant
although
uh
still small sliver
of the population that just
likes raw meat like that
and so to the extent that
that it becomes commercialized then it
may get ginned up
uh in the same way that wwf wrestling
you know gets agenda and promoted um and
and i think that we're all going to have
to
be careful about that
[Applause]
as you demonstrated in your keynote
address this summer you are not afraid
to differentiate beyond the typical
television or political personality
and i was interested to hear the
inspector general who just retired a
couple years ago from the cia
say that al qaeda and these people don't
hate us for who we are but
for what we do
for certain acts that have occurred in
the past and i was wondering if you
could differentiate
amongst the generalities of them hating
us for
what values or flag or something
as to
specifically why you think the tension
was created to where osama bin laden
would have a 70 percent approval rating
in pakistan
well
the uh
a couple of things i i think you know
there's obviously a big question i may
not be able to answer it completely here
i'll start by talking about
a passage that's in my book actually a
chapter is devoted to
the three four years that i spend in
indonesia which is actually the largest
muslim country in the world
and when i arrived uh indonesia had its
own problems because there had been a
uh
a leader of the non-aligned movement
called tsukarno who was overthrown in a
military coup the cia had assisted in
that coup about half a million people
had been killed
but i was sick so
i wasn't paying attention to all this
um and my mother who was only at the
time 24 really didn't understand the
history of it she had remarried in
indonesia
that's all
slightly beside the point what what is
true though is is that
indonesia at that time was an explicitly
secular government despite the fact that
there was the devout practice of islam
throughout the country and so women were
able to wear skirts and ride vespas and
work and
there was very little
religious strife
and
then
after the asian financial crisis uh the
real incomes of the average indonesian
dropped by about 30 percent
and it's right about that time that al
qaeda began to get a foothold
in
indonesia
and now
you know there are powerful strains of a
perverted brand of fundamentalist islam
that have taken root uh in in that
country
now
i'm not somebody who draws a direct line
between
poverty and fanaticism or nihilism
and i'm not interested actually in
making too many excuses for
somebody who
would see people with such
as as such abstractions
with such contempt
that they would be willing to
kill
3 000 people
and think that they're making a
political statement um
i i i i there are no excuses for that
and and that's where my empathy stops
and i can't get into that mindset
but
what i can understand
is that if a child in pakistan
has
no prospects
no future
has watched their parents grind out
terrible
subsistence existence
and then the only avenues that they have
for
not only
advancement but just some
sense of meaning in their lives
is a madrassas
in which they are drilled with
a
very narrow fundamentalist brand
of islam that then translates itself
potentially into
violent political acts not always but
sometimes
that there's a connection there
and that our foreign policy and our
perspective
with respect to how to deal with
terrorism has to reflect
not only the interest in stopping the
immediate threat of terrorism but also
in
creating
a
a foreign policy that promotes justice
that promotes economic development that
promotes the rights of women uh
and that
those are all central
aspects uh to
to dealing with terrorism uh ultimately
terrorism is a tactic
it's it's not
uh we're not fighting terrorists we're
fighting
people who engage in terrorism
but have a whole host of
of
rationales
and excuses for why they do this and to
the extent that we can
change
the sense of opportunity in many of
these countries and we can change the
the manner in which we function
in these countries in more positive
proactive ways then we're not going to
eliminate terrorism entirely but we're
at least going to be able to make more
of a dent than if all we're resorting to
is military firepower
[Applause]
we only have time for two more questions
senator
um i have a comment and a question i
read your book and loved it thought it
was very well written i was put yes it
is and um
the part that really fascinated me
though was the part where you go to
africa to visit your relatives and so my
question is what was the reaction
uh from your relatives to your recent
election
and are they coming to the inaugural
well the uh
you know this has been
sort of
nothing that i could have imagined
um we're big in kenya right now
[Applause]
the obama um
[Applause]
you know somebody
you know went out in safari somewhere
and they
saw some masai and traditional garb and
who'd somehow got an obama button
and uh
um
so so so we've been we've been big news
and we've been big news in kenya
as well as the entire
uh
you know continent um
you know my my understanding is the same
is true in south africa and other places
and and obviously you know that's that's
heartening although i think their
information is not always right you know
there's there was an article about you
know
uh
a uh
a little boy who was sure that you know
i just wan i was running against george
bush
so i that i had defeated him
um
and
and then and then there was there was a
uh
and there's there's also a danger to it
in the sense that
my election then gets invested with a
lot of
expectations partly because africa
traditionally
uh and negatively by the way thinks of
politics in
what's been called the big man model the
notion is is that
the big man gets elected and then
you know he dispenses favors and gifts
upon
uh those who are his people and so
almost immediately after even before my
election people were saying well once
obama's elected he's we're going to get
tarmacked roads and new schools and
and so when i go back and you know i'm
still broke
and i try to explain to them that i'm 99
uh in seniority they you know i'm not
sure how that's going to play
they may kick me back out
um but uh but you know
obviously it is uh
very touching the degree to which
people have responded and
i
take
that
um
that role seriously
in the sense that
one of the biggest challenges that i'm
going to face is making sure that
i
am
singularly focused on serving the state
of illinois
and the people who elected me and doing
a good job
but that i'm also
even as i do that
am able and willing to give voice to the
voiceless in the corridors of power
where necessary so
um you know i'm going to be
um
you know so i have no qualms about
speaking out on issues that are of
particular interest to africa or
african americans or latinos or other
minorities that are not
always well represented but i
particularly
now as i begin my career my whole
orientation
is going to be to make sure that i'm the
best possible senator from the state of
illinois i will not serve anybody else
well
if the folks back home
start looking and saying the man's not
answering his mail and he's not
you know uh he's not returning phone
calls and my social security check's
still late and he hasn't done anything
to help so
okay
so unfortunately i think this is the
last question is that right
yeah
and um i think i speak for everybody i
think what we do need is for you to do
your job for the people of illinois and
if and when you're ready to make that
move we'll all be here for you well
but
with that said though obviously as you
can tell there's there must be an
enormous amount of pressure on you being
the quote-unquote rising star of the
democratic party how are you handling
that right now you know i i mean i i'll
be honest with you maybe i'm just not
too bright because i don't feel that
much pressure
i
i i uh um
i mean
there are some
nuts and bolts aspects of
this modest celebrity that i've achieved
that are
that have to be dealt with i mean i will
probably get a significantly higher
volume of mail
than the average senator because people
from outside the state
think that i'm going to be able to do
something for them and and so
i've got to tell you guys if you plan to
write me a letter
i may not be able to respond to the
folks in new york i apologize in advance
um but
uh
you know we're getting a lot
more invitations you know we've gotten
probably 200 invitations a week to speak
at every
you know progressive organization and
naacp freedom fund dinner and
uh and you know so unfortunately i'm
gonna have to say no more than maybe
i would prefer to
uh as a freshman senator but
but in terms of i think heightened
expectations and how am i feeling about
that
i'm not feeling uh very stressed about
it
primarily because
what i'm most concerned about are
meeting
number one the expectations of the
people of illinois who gave me this
great honor
and they're a pretty sophisticated bunch
they know that it takes time to get
things done in washington what they want
to know is
that
i'm waking up every morning thinking
about how to make their lives better and
then i'm going to be consistent with the
principles that i laid out in the
campaign
in terms of trying to improve education
and trying to
make healthcare more accessible and
affordable and as long as i'm
moving the ball in the right direction
moving the ball downfield even if it's
you know
an inch at a time or a foot at a time
and they know that i'm working hard on
their behalf then those are expectations
i think i can meet
i have my family's
expectations that i will conduct myself
in a way that makes them proud which
means i'm honest and i've got integrity
and that
i
am thinking about them
even in the maelstrom of
work
that
i'm going to be engaged in so i've got
expectation my six-year-old and
three-year-old have expectations that i
met this weekend
taking them to spongebob squarepants
but those are expectations that i've got
to meet
um
and
and then i've got my own expectations
and and and my own expectations i think
are that
um that i continually do this
uh not because i'm
interested in a particular political
title
or
like
people calling me senator but that i'm
doing it because
i've got a core set of values that
i think have to be advanced
um
and and
that i my individual salvation depends
on
our collective salvation so all right
thank you very much everybody
my name is matt hi matt how are you very
good to meet you thank you man all right
so how are we gonna we're gonna start
with the lady over i got my own pen just
because these tend to leach through so
i'll hold them in case uh that runs out
i mean if we have another felt-tip pen
you know
you know that's not gonna leach through
because i always feel bad
um
no we're going to start with her yeah go
ahead okay
good okay all right
thank you thanks for being here
this guy single-handedly is uh
is going to send my kids through college
making it easy on me
oh yeah and by the way you know how you
get my vote for my wife let's go on the
view you got it yeah i know you already
she was on the show
i just filed him right here
well it's very what's your name bert
bert good to see you man where do you
live great to see you
thank you
good luck to you thank you i appreciate
it
where do you live burke the grain
of new york two hours from here is that
right i've been seeing that [ __ ] for
three hours
what kind of work you do i work for the
defender fantastic
how's the how's rail service doing all
right
all right one of the better ones
absolutely they treating you guys okay
oh yeah you know it's a senator on the
front of that
okay what's
[Music]
these
i don't
there you go is uh doing his christmas
shopping well i appreciate that i have
friends who can't be here rather than
events going on so
after all this you tell me which one's
for you and i'll sign i'll i'll
personalize that one
if you just dated you'd be fine okay
what do you do
i'm a return i'm a retired teacher oh
wonderful
work at new york city for 35 years
what'd you teach uh social studies
computers math is that right they're one
of the public schools one of the public
schools in town yeah
you miss it
yes you missed the kids yeah my sister
taught
in new york on the lower east side
south province is that right
you can thank that one and the uh the
other two
what's the date
[Music]
there today go
i was disappointed that you said you're
not going to answer your mail
because i want that uh you know
something to autograph
you know it's just going to be yeah but
i know you're
it's just going to be impossible
you know i'll visit you personally my
daughter works in washington all right
uh
that's all yours oh this is your pick
thank you thank you very much thank you
sir how are you what's your name chris
nice to see you chris
you going to school or working yeah yeah
where you go to school
okay thank you great to see you
absolutely thank you very much
this is shirai he was next in line for i
know i felt bad how are you okay good to
see you
by the way truth is often the best
corrective
i like it if you could to read i mean
this page if you could okay if you like
read the rest of it all right thank you
do a review
okay i appreciate that thank you this is
uh for andrew
how are you what's your name
nice to meet you
andrew thanks for coming here absolutely
what what what gradient andrew um
yeah i don't do this for everybody
andrew but
i'm gonna write you a little message
thank you so much since since you're
just getting started right here
hopefully i'll be able to
be one of your my neighbors all right
thank you thank you thank you thank you
how are you
well you've asked other people's names
thank you so much with kenny johnson
you're shooting this for cheers
how are you
so nice to meet you what's your name
definitely nice to see you beverly hills
it's great to see you thanks so much for
coming today i appreciate you
and she has one
more you're so depressed with the
election senator but you're giving us
hope well i tell you what we just gotta
pick ourselves up dust ourselves off
keep going
thank you please uh listen you wouldn't
mind stepping back around this side how
are you
hello senator you make me feel the most
enormous relief well that's so nice
what's your name natalie nice to see you
natalie
do you have one of these books for you
oh i do all right i'm gonna sign the
last one just for you that's so
wonderful uh i was going to warn you
about keeping your integrity but i know
that i don't have to worry you're so
authentic i love it well i appreciate
that
when you come to the states natalie
sure
no no no but you weren't born here
oh i yeah
not london no that's what i thought yes
is natalie uh traditional spelling
n-a-t-a l-i-e
and you have a natasha huh i do yeah i
get called natasha sometimes yeah
but
you said everything i needed to hear i'm
absolutely thrilled
thank you thank you so much appreciate
it
hi i'm christina nice to see you fatima
i love that name
so far so good well i appreciate that
thank you so much
hi how are you what's your name clara
nice to meet you
you can send an email to our website and
just and right now
well we've got about 600 700 that we've
got to sort through
do you have any hill experience
do i have any hill experience and then
what would that be i don't know i may
have you worked in washington before oh
the hill i'm like no i'm uh
well no it's it's it's not a requirement
i was just curious no no i'm sorry okay
we're good
hi how are you
nice to meet you thank you so much
i really really appreciate it thanks for
being here thank you so much good who's
whose book did i just sign uh that was
hers and this is hers as well both of
these okay thank you so much
appreciate it yes
hi no she's not 93. look at her she's
too surprised
barack obama will be sworn in as the
junior senator from illinois in january
dreams for my father is published by
three rivers press and imprint of crown
visit crownpublishing.com